Hi, I'm Amy Jo Kim,
designer, entrepreneur,
and startup coach.
I've worked with dozens of
startups and game studios
to bring their
early ideas to life
by creating an MVP,
Minimum Viable Product.
Through trial and error,
I've learned what works
and what doesn't at the
early stages of innovation.
I synthesized these lessons
into a set of techniques
I call MVP Design Hacks.
Today, I'm going to teach you
a quick, effective hack that's
a great way to kick
off your MVP process.
It's called the
MVP Design Canvas.
This one-page document
gives your team
a highly-useful tool for
articulating and evolving
your product strategy
and key assumptions.
This has places for you to
write down your initial thoughts
about who your customers are,
what their unmet needs are,
what problem you're solving,
what solution you're coming up
with to solve that problem.
The value prop your solution
delivers, the unfair advantage
or competitive edge
that you and your team
have that makes you ideally
suited to solving this problem,
the early metrics that you'll
use to gauge whether you're
on the right track;
and then, finally,
the key assumptions that you
have going into this project
that you need to test to
determine whether or not
this is a viable idea
that's worth pursuing.
You'll use this canvas, as
your assumptions get tested
and refined, throughout
your development process.
To update and communicate
your new vision strategy
and direction to your
team and any investors
or interested people.
It's a great tool to
help you and your team
stay strategically aligned.
Let's see how this design
canvas works in action.
Let me tell you a story about
a recent client I worked with.
Let's call them Toy Co.
They're part of the
Collaborative Consumption
movement.
They're a toy rental
company, initially
specializing in building toys.
We worked through our
kickoff questionnaire,
and found we had a lot
of unanswered questions--
some very clear assumptions.
Like many companies, Toy
Co started with a solution.
They had this idea that a
digital community, where people
could connect around
their shared love of toys,
would be a great thing
for their company,
for driving the metrics
they're interested in.
Particularly
satisfaction retention,
and the length of time
each rental was out.
So we took that as
a starting point,
and then fleshed out the
rest of our assumptions.
After completing this
Design Canvas exercise,
our assumptions were
clear, and we set out
to test that assumption and see
what our members really wanted.
Through a series of
surveys and interviews
we identified a handful
of early adopters,
sketched up our ideas, and walk
them through the possibilities.
Here's what we learned.
First of all, let's
look at the solution.
We found that, in fact, none
of the members we talked to
were interested in the
solution we were proposing.
However, they were interested
in video content related
to the toys that would entertain
and educate their children,
and keep them busy.
We found this out
through our interviews.
We discovered our early
customers had an unmet need
that we knew nothing about.
Which was a need for
curated, wholesome,
family-friendly
content they could
trust that would feed their
kids' building toys habit.
Certain kids, when
they're a certain age,
this is all they want to do.
And these parents,
these enthusiast,
these early adopters, were very
clear that that was something
they were seeking, and did
not have a great solution for.
So the value prop, rather
than being connected
with other parents, was actually
enriching video content.
Trusted by the parents that
they could show to their kids,
so they could make a phone
call, take dinner off the stove,
have a few minutes with their
husband at the end of the day.
That was the need we identified
that we knew nothing about.
So we change the solution
that we had in mind
to be this curated
video collection.
Turns out, our MVP
is a YouTube channel.
Not building some
technology ourselves,
but simply developing
some content
and testing it with our users
by using the YouTube platform.
The unfair advantage
remains the same.
The metrics basically
remain the same.
And the assumption
that we tested
resulted in a pivot of our
focus for our digital community,
based on what we know our
members want and need,
without building a single
piece of technology,
or writing a single
line of code.
That's the power
of using this MVP
Canvas to think through
and test your assumptions.
I hope this example
has inspired you
to try this exercise
with your own ideas.
It's a great way to
crystallize and communicate
what you're doing.
And a great tool for
tracking and communicating
changes to your project as
you're thinking evolves.
If you can put aside
your confidence,
and take the mindset and
point of view of a scientist,
and run your MVP ideas through
the gauntlet of testing it
with real users.
You will save time, money,
and greatly increase
your chances of success.
Good luck with your project.
And be sure to go to MVP Design
Hacks for more information,
more design hacks, and
an eight-week program
that startups can use to
turbo charge their MVPs.
Thank you.